back in june a bunch of hackers stole a
mountain of data from developer
publisher electronic arts
including the source code for the fifa
and battlefield franchises
as well as the frostbite development
engine now initially the hackers tried
to extort ea for money but
when that did not go well they publicly
dumped a bunch of that stolen
data and this whole hack actually
started through the workplace management
app
slack
guys if you wanna see more hacking
videos like this you gotta like the
video you gotta subscribe to the channel
you gotta hit that notification bell so
you never miss new content and
you gotta send your story ideas to tips
at thescore.com
back on june 10th motherboard reported
that ea had
suffered a massive hack ea got goatseed
sorry i think the best way to say is
they got hacked but i like the term
goats a little bit more you know ea
servers got a little
stretched if you will right the group
claiming responsibility for the hack
stated that they
stole roughly 780 gigabytes worth of
data
including the source code for fifa 21
its matchmaking server
and the frostbite development engine if
you didn't know frostbite is the engine
with which ea has made most of its
recent games and franchises
fifa 21 the battlefield series star wars
etc but what does that actually mean
like why is it such a big deal
that the source code for these games was
stolen well there's a bunch of different
reasons but if you think about it from a
cheating perspective if you're someone
who makes cheats and you've stolen the
source code to these games
you essentially have the blueprint for
fifa
or battlefield at your fingertips
essentially everything you would need to
know to get around ea's anti-cheat
infrastructure is
right there in front of you not to
mention you could straight up sell that
information
for a [ __ ] ton of money which is exactly
what
these hackers tried to do and according
to a new york times report
one of these listings that was selling
the stolen data
was apparently going for roughly 500
000 even back in may now apparently the
hackers were advertising this stolen
data on
underground forums one which motherboard
has confirmed
to have seen i reached out to ea for
comment about this initial hack
here's what they had to say we are
investigating a recent incident of
intrusion into our network
where a limited amount of game source
code and related tools were stolen
no player data was accessed and we have
no reason to believe there's any risk to
player privacy
following the incident we've already
made security improvements and do not
expect an impact on our games or our
business
we are actively working with law
enforcement officials and other experts
as a part of this ongoing criminal
investigation end quote
so yeah it's worth pointing out that we
now know there is an ongoing criminal
investigation
related to this hack then just this week
on july 14th
after the hacker stated that ea had
failed to respond to their extortion
threats
they publicly released part of that
stolen data
here's what ea had to say on this latest
development quote
this week we've been made aware of an
extortion threat from the alleged
hackers
and a portion of some files were
released to the public we've analyzed
the files released by the alleged
hackers and at this time we continue to
believe it does not contain data that
poses any concern to player privacy
and we have no reason to believe there's
any material risk to our games
our business or our players we continue
to work with federal law enforcement
officials as a part of this ongoing
criminal investigation
now the strangest part of this hack to
me anyway is how they pulled it off
see these hackers gained access to ea
servers and all of that stolen data
through slack and if you don't know what
slack is think of it as a messenger
platform for
the workplace keith tells me to book
meetings for these videos
i grumble and complain and do it anyway
you get the point
here's a rough breakdown of how the hack
happened these hackers apparently bought
stolen cookies through a
invite only dark net marketplace
referred to as
genesis market now most of you know i'm
not referring to literal cookies rather
the
technology that saves all of your
information or browsing habits from
every website or frankly literally every
interaction you've ever had on the
internet
now technically speaking people who use
genesis market aren't just buying a
single cookie from a hacked computer
no often they're buying access to a bot
which is essentially a computer that's
been hacked into
and is a part of something called a
botnet and devices that find themselves
on a botnet like this
often have a ton of sensitive
information available for purchase
on top of that in simple terms the
genesis market also offers the ability
to create a one-to-one mask
of that device's browser with all of the
saved
cookies and information included and if
someone's slack information
was saved through one of those stolen
cookies off one of those faked
browsers it would be incredibly easy to
impersonate that person
on slack which is exactly what the
hackers
did according to motherboard the process
of the hack started after the hackers
spent ten dollars on a set of stolen
cookies that then gave them access to
ea's slack
channel after that they've left their
way through it past two-factor
authentication and into ea's more
sensitive systems
and then from there the rest is history
they stole
a [ __ ] ton of data now that hack might
have been the biggest security threat ea
has had to deal with this month but it's
not
the only issue that an ea specific
entity has had to deal with recently
back in april apex legends and titanfall
developer respawn entertainment which is
owned by ea
was hacked see a bunch of angry
titanfall fans hacked their way into
apex legends
to complain about the fact that
titanfall was suffering
from an abundance of cheaters seriously
fans of the fast-paced battle royale
were treated to hashtag
save titanfall splattered all over
their ui on top of that the servers were
shot to [ __ ] and players on mass could
not connect to matches
now if you're wondering why people are
trying to save titanfall
let me explain see both titanfall 1 and
2
are really good criminally underrated
games that have small but die-hard
communities
attached to them and back in april due
to a surge in popularity
respawn made titanfall 2 free to play
for an entire weekend
undoubtedly this brought in a fresh wave
of new players
but potentially it also brought in more
cheaters as well
it was kind of nuts in a two-day period
the player base skyrocketed 650 percent
now in terms of the hack talk about
timing it happened on july 4th
of all days multiple respawn devs
tweeted out saying that this hack didn't
really do anything
rather it just pissed a bunch of people
off and made them work
on well their day off furthermore
director of communications ryan rigney
tweeted out that the hackers quote
achieved nothing of value
and that respawn had been made aware of
this issue a long time ago
this situation is one of a much larger
chronic cheating problem that apex
legends has been dealing with
for months at this point from chronic
ddos attacks to cheaters holding
high-level lobbies hostage
apex legends is in dire need of better
security we've reported on this issue
multiple times on this
show before fans have been complaining
about cheetahs ruining their rank
matches
for a long time now on top of that
there's also been
countless reports of hackers using
targeted ddos attacks
to crash their games and make life hell
for everyone involved
on top of the two ea related hacks
cyberpunk 2077 and the witcher developer
cd projekt
red suffered a major hack back in
february of this year
that they're still dealing with today in
that instance the source code for
cyberpunk and the witcher 3 were stolen
now at the time
cd projekt red downplayed the severity
of the hack to the public
but then during this year's e3 in june
the developer stated that the hack was
actually much worse than they initially
thought
and that some employee data might have
been stolen
during the hack in all of these cases
that we've talked about today the
authorities have been
contacted and investigations are ongoing
that's it for now it's
unclear at the moment how much of that
stolen data has been made
public and whether or not that
information has been used
to further harm the company ea says that
the stolen data has not been used to
harm the player base in any way
i.e the sensitive information from
players has not been leaked but
still the source code for multiple games
stolen through slack that's a disaster
that's
not going to go away immediately
could you just picture me as willy wonka
all those kids would be
here get them out of here take your
golden ticket kiss my ass man
all you bratty pieces of [ __ ] you know
just
in that instance these cyber the cyber
code
what the [ __ ] is going on they stole the
cyber code